Brava!
Allora, immaginate di essere a Washington il 14 aprile del 1865, sono passati 5 giorni da quando il generale Robert Lee, il comandante dell'esercito sudista,
ha capitolato ad Appomattox mettendo fine alla guerra civile americana. Il presidente Lincoln è a teatro a vedere una commedia, mentre la rappresentazione è in corso nel teatro entra un attore, un famosissimo attore di teatro, talmente famoso che nessuno lo controlla, nessuno lo ferma perché lì è di casa, è molto giovane, ha solo 27 anni ma da parecchi anni è uno degli attori più famosi d'America,
in un'epoca, capite, in cui il teatro aveva lo stesso spazio che oggi hanno la tv, il cinema e anche qualcosa di più probabilmente, questo attore da anni i giornali lo esaltano, lo chiamano l'uomo più bello d'America.
Si chiama John Wilkes Booth ed è un simpatizzante del sud che ha appena perso la guerra civile e non ha mai nascosto di odiare il presidente Lincoln che vede come appunto la causa di tutti i mali del sud,
una volta è stato anche arrestato per i discorsi che faceva in giro contro il governo. John Wilkes Booth, l'uomo più bello d'America, entra nel palco presidenziale senza che nessuno controlli,
altri tempi come capite, tira fuori la pistola e spara alla nuca del presidente. Un ufficiale cerca di fermarlo, lui tira fuori un pugnale, pugnala l'ufficiale e scappa,
convinto di essere come brutto che ha ammazzato Giulio Cesare per difendere la libertà. Morirà due settimane dopo in uno scontro a fuoco con la cavalleria che lo ha seguito nella sua fuga.
Lincoln è il primo presidente degli Stati Uniti a morire in un attentato e come sapete non sarà l'ultimo, dopo di lui altri tre presidenti degli Stati Uniti
verranno ammazzati mentre sono in carica, l'ultimo è Jack Kennedy naturalmente. La morte di Lincoln è un momento di svolta nella conclusione di una guerra civile
che era costata all'America 600.000 morti, in altre parole molti più morti di tutti quelli delle guerre americane del Novecento.
Una guerra che era stata scatenata proprio dall'elezione di Lincoln a presidente degli Stati Uniti nelle elezioni del novembre 1860.
Lincoln, candidato repubblicano, ma vedremo presto che allora democratici e repubblicani, anche se esistevano già, non coprivano lo stesso spettro elettorale che coprono oggi.
Lincoln era stato eletto col 40% del voto popolare, quindi una maggioranza relativa, anche perché all'epoca non usava come adesso avere solo due candidati,
ce n'erano di più. Nelle elezioni del 1860 i candidati sono quattro. Lincoln ha la maggioranza relativa, vince in tutto il nord,
nella maggior parte degli stati schiavisti del sud non prende neanche un voto. Un paese spaccato quindi.
Oggi negli Stati Uniti la divisione dell'elettorato fra quelli che votano Trump e quelli che votano Biden evoca spesso scenari
da guerra civile. Chi ha conoscenti americani sa che credono davvero che il paese sia quasi a rischio di conoscere di nuovo
un'esperienza del genere talmente è spaccato oggi.
In realtà quando uno studia l'origine della guerra civile americana ci si rende conto che prima che un paese precipiti davvero
nella guerra civile non basta, non basta che ci sia una spaccatura dell'opinione pubblica, che ci sia una percentuale anche
consistente della popolazione che è contraria al sistema, non basta.
La guerra civile in America nell'Ottocento è scoppiata perché nel paese si confrontavano due diversi modelli di sviluppo,
di economia, di società, ognuno radicato in una parte degli Stati Uniti e ognuno di questi due modelli contrapposti
era così radicato che in realtà tutti ci credevano, non soltanto appunto i poveracci che si sentono esclusi,
ma i politici, ma gli intellettuali, ma i ricchi, ma gli ideologi.
Allora cos'era che nell'Ottocento ha diviso così profondamente gli Stati Uniti da farli precipitare nella guerra civile?
E che cosa sono gli Stati Uniti alla metà dell'Ottocento?
Qualche dato, gli Stati Uniti nel 1860 hanno 31 milioni di abitanti, a noi verrebbe da ridere, oggi ne hanno 300 milioni,
ma per la metà dell'Ottocento è una popolazione molto importante, 31 milioni di abitanti vuol dire che gli Stati Uniti
hanno più abitanti della Gran Bretagna e ne hanno appena un po' meno della Francia,
e sto parlando delle due più grandi potenze mondiali, dei due paesi all'avanguardia in Europa
che hanno già dei vasti imperi coloniali nel resto del mondo, quindi gli Stati Uniti sono potenzialmente già
una delle grandi potenze mondiali, ma la cosa più impressionante è questa, che nel 1860 hanno 31 milioni di abitanti,
ma dieci anni prima ne avevano solo 23 milioni, il che vuol dire che in un decennio la popolazione è aumentata di un terzo,
il paese sta crescendo enormemente, si riempie di immigrati e sta conoscendo una colossale crescita industriale,
i decenni centrali dell'Ottocento, lo sapete, sono di crescita industriale travolgente nei paesi d'avanguardia,
in Gran Bretagna, in Germania, in Francia, negli Stati Uniti.
In quel decennio, 50-60, il valore della produzione industriale negli Stati Uniti si è raddoppiato.
Quando si parla di cifre è bene fermarsi un attimo a riflettere, avete presente come noi lottiamo con lo 0,5 annuo,
l'1% annuo di aumento, ecco, qui parliamo di un raddoppio nell'arco di dieci anni.
Per il momento sono ancora un paese in cui i contadini sono più numerosi degli abitanti delle città,
ma il sorpasso sta già per arrivare.
Ci sono negli Stati Uniti nel 1860 53.000 chilometri di ferrovie funzionanti, più quelle in costruzione,
53.000 chilometri, in tutta Italia, alla stessa data, 1.800 chilometri.
Per di più, per di più è una società unica al mondo perché è una società democratica,
col suffragio universale che non c'è in nessun paese d'Europa,
intendiamoci, il suffragio universale come lo concepivano loro, maschile,
però c'è già un movimento femminile che chiede la parità dei diritti e il voto anche per le donne.
Le uniche disuguaglianze sono quelle economiche, ma attenzione,
mentre oggi gli Stati Uniti, lo sappiamo, fra i paesi occidentali
sono quello dove la disuguaglianza fra i super ricchi e i poveri è più ampia,
ancora, anche se noi in Italia li stiamo rapidamente raggiungendo,
all'epoca gli Stati Uniti sono il paese più egualitario del mondo,
le disuguaglianze sono più ridotte che non altrove,
i salari sono molto più forti che non in Europa,
il che spiega quella marea di emigranti che dalla Germania, dalla Polonia e anche dall'Italia
ormai stava cominciando ad arrivare negli Stati Uniti.
Il tasso di alfabetizzazione è altissimo, negli Stati Uniti il 90% della popolazione bianca
sa leggere e scrivere, in Italia alla stessa data 20%, Stati Uniti 90%, tutti leggono il giornale.
Allora, questo quadro complessivo è vero di tutto il paese ma fino a un certo punto
il discorso sulla democrazia, l'egualitarismo, l'alfabetizzazione vale in tutto il paese,
anche se forse al nord questi fattori sono ancora più accentuati che non al sud,
ma l'enorme sviluppo industriale, l'immigrazione, la massa di gente che arriva,
lo sviluppo e la trasformazione costante caratterizzano solo il nord.
Il nord ha tre quarti degli abitanti ma ha quasi tutte le fabbriche, quasi tutti gli operai.
Il sud è ricco ma è un paese interamente agricolo dove la ricchezza consiste nelle piantagioni e negli schiavi.
Capite? Quattro milioni di schiavi sono un capitale gigantesco.
Il sud possiede quattro milioni di schiavi quindi sulla carta è proprietario di una colossale ricchezza
ed è straricco grazie ai profitti del cotone che nel sud è diventato ormai una monocultura,
c'è ancora un po' di tabacco in Virginia ma mentre il sud un secolo prima era un paese dove si produceva appunto
il tabacco, lo zucchero, il riso, nel 1860 il sud è il paese del cotone
ed è il paese del cotone perché c'è la rivoluzione industriale in corso.
In Inghilterra le filature di Manchester mangiano ogni anno una montagna di cotone
e questo cotone arriva dagli stati del sud.
Grazie al capitale immobilizzato in quattro milioni di schiavi e agli enormi profitti del cotone
il sud è straricco ma è un'economia ferma che non sta crescendo e non si sta trasformando.
Il nord invece è in profondissima trasformazione e tuttavia fino alla metà del secolo il sud
ha diretto politicamente gli Stati Uniti, l'elite dei grandi proprietari terrieri, dei piantatori del sud
ha dominato la politica degli Stati Uniti.
Lincoln è il sedicesimo presidente, su 15 presidenti prima di Lincoln 9 venivano dagli Stati del sud
e di loro 8 erano proprietari di schiavi.
Capite? Fino all'elezione di Lincoln un po' più di metà dei presidenti degli Stati Uniti
erano personalmente proprietari di schiavi e anche quelli che venivano dal nord sono sempre stati eletti
in base ad accordi elettorali con i piantatori del sud.
Non c'è mai stato un presidente che si opponesse agli interessi del sud.
E questa egemonia politica del sud in realtà, come dire, si spiega col fatto che anche se io finora ho parlato di nord e sud
in realtà gli Stati Uniti non erano divisi in due, erano divisi in tre
perché c'era anche l'ovest o come dicevano loro il west, il nord, il nord con al cuore il New England puritano
il Connecticut, il Massachusetts e con la grande metropoli di New York
il nord è commerciale, portuale, affarista, industriale, in tumultuosa crescita demografica
dominato dal capitalismo commerciale e industriale.
Il sud è agricolo, produce il cotone e poi lo manda al nord perché non ha neanche buoni porti.
Il sud di fatto vive di quello, è in mano a un'elite di piantatori e vive di un'economia basata sulla schiavitù.
e poi c'è l'ovest perché il continente americano è ancora in gran parte da colonizzare
agli occhi dei bianchi non è di nessuno, noi sappiamo che ci vivono innumerevoli nazioni indiane
per usare il termine che si usava una volta, nazioni indigene, native
agli occhi dei bianchi è come se non ci fosse nessuno, è un mondo da conquistare
il west che stanno conquistando in quegli anni non è ancora il far west dei cowboys
è quello che oggi si chiama il middle west
paese di coloni, di contadini che arrivano lì e la terra c'è per tutti
il governo distribuisce la terra gratis
se arrivi ti fabbrichi la tua capanna di tronchi e ti metti a coltivare la terra non costa niente
te la danno
ovviamente è una società anche questa, egualitaria
la più egualitaria è d'America
è una società individualista
ed è una società contadina
il fatto che il west è un mondo di contadini
spiega come mai per molto tempo il west e il sud sono alleati
perché fondamentalmente hanno gli stessi interessi
sono interessati alla difesa dell'agricoltura e non degli interessi industriali
e poi sono interessati all'espansione territoriale
l'espansione territoriale vuol dire che l'America e gli Stati Uniti devono trovare spazio
per la marea di immigrati che stanno arrivando
si devono espandere verso ovest e anche i piantatori del sud hanno una gran voglia di espandersi verso ovest
l'ovest è grande ma c'è poi tutto il sud ovest
la guerra contro il Messico del 1848
di cui noi non ci ricordiamo niente
chi è che sa che gli Stati Uniti hanno fatto la guerra al Messico nel 1848
al massimo ci ricordiamo di Fort Alamo
di Davy Crockett per qualche film di Hollywood
la guerra del 1848 è un momento epocale in cui gli Stati Uniti sconfiggendo il Messico
si impadroniscono di immensi territori
il Texas, il New Mexico, la California
e quella guerra l'hanno voluta i piantatori del sud
e i coloni dell'ovest alleati
e rappresentati in politica da un partito
che esiste ancora oggi
che era il partito democratico
a noi può sembrare strano che il partito dei piantatori del sud fosse il partito democratico
in realtà chi ha la mia età si ricorda che ancora negli anni 60 il sud votava democratico
poi con Reagan si è messo a votare repubblicano
e adesso è il baluardo dei repubblicani e di Trump
ma per tanto tempo al sud hanno dato per scontato che il loro partito era il partito democratico
nell'ottocento il partito del sud era il partito democratico ed era anche il partito dei coloni
dei piccoli proprietari dell'ovest
solo che questa coalizione
alla metà dell'ottocento
comincia a essere minacciata
perché di fronte alla coalizione dei contadini e dei piantatori
gli industriali del nord
contano sempre di più
e loro vogliono politiche diverse
da quelle che convengono all'agricoltura
il primo momento in cui ci si rende conto
che è impossibile avere una politica economica
che vada bene a tutti
e che quindi si dovrà per forza andare allo scontro
allo scontro politico
ben inteso all'inizio nessuno pensa ad altro
ma lo scontro politico diventa inevitabile
nel momento in cui gli industriali del nord reclamano
come succede anche oggi
avete presente i dazzi contro la Cina
ecco
all'industria americana convengono i dazzi
noi vogliamo che le merci che vengono dall'Inghilterra costino troppo
i nostri abitanti devono comprare la nostra roba
la nostra produzione industriale
quindi tariffe
i piantatori del sud
le tariffe non le vogliono
loro vivono di esportazione
vivono esportando il cotone
guai se gli inglesi si arrabbiano
e cominciano a mettere tariffe sul cotone americano
magari vi sembra poco
è un conflitto economico
ce ne sono continuamente nei paesi avanzati
eppure su quel conflitto economico
si comincia a intravedere la base di una spaccatura drammatica degli Stati Uniti
perché quello che succede è che ogni volta che la lobby degli industriali a Washington
cerca di ottenere una politica favorevole per loro
tariffe doganali
quindi al sud qualcuno comincia a dire che a loro non importa se il governo di Washington decide queste cose perché i singoli stati non sono mica obbligati a fare quello che dice Washington
gli Stati Uniti sono un'unione di stati liberi
ognuno dei quali ha aderito volontariamente
e non è obbligato a rispettare le leggi federali
capite?
voglio dire noi viviamo nell'Europa della Brexit
capite quanto è grosso il problema di stabilire fin dove puoi andare
fin dove ti puoi spingere
una volta che hai deciso di entrare dentro un'unione
al sud il discorso è noi di leggi contrarie ai nostri interessi non ne vogliamo
se voi le fate noi non le applichiamo
nel 1832
mancano ancora 30 anni
all'elezione di Lincoln
è una storia lunga come vedete
quella delle origini della guerra civile
nel 1832 Washington passa una legge che impone tariffe doganali più alte
è uno degli stati del sud
lo stato più estremista del sud
uno dei pochissimi dove gli schiavi neri sono addirittura più numerosi degli abitanti bianchi
è lo stesso stato che poi sarà il più estremista
è il primo a dichiarare la secessione 30 anni dopo
il South Carolina
nel 1832 il South Carolina davanti a una legge federale che impone nuove tariffe doganali
dichiara che per quanto riguarda l'or del South Carolina quella legge è nulla
lo stato del South Carolina è libero di nullificare dicono loro le leggi di Washington
si apre un dibattito politico violentissimo che è passato alla storia appunto come il dibattito sulla nullificazione
e lì per la prima volta si comincia a discutere su cosa sono davvero gli Stati Uniti
e entra in scena uno dei grandi politici americani dell'epoca
un personaggio che noi oggi in Italia conosciamo pochissimo naturalmente
morirà prima della guerra civile
è uno dei grandi politici che rappresentano gli interessi del sud
si chiama Cullen, John Cullen
è un intellettuale profondissimo
un difensore della schiavitù come l'unico sistema con cui il sud può vivere
e nel dibattito sulla nullificazione
John Cullen a nome di tutto il sud
dichiara
che anche se ci siamo uniti
ognuno dei singoli stati
conserva la sua piena sovranità
gli stati sono i sovrani
e il governo federale a Washington è soltanto il loro agente
e che non c'è nessun obbligo di obbedire al governo di Washington
perché questa è una cosa che semmai si può fare negli Stati nazionali
dove l'interesse nazionale è unico
e gli Stati Uniti non sono la stessa cosa
John Cullen dichiara espressamente
cito
noi non siamo una nazione
ma un'unione
una confederazione di stati uguali e sovrani
l'Inghilterra è una nazione
gli Stati Uniti non lo sono
di fronte a questa posizione
gli ideologi del nord invece
argomentano che gli Stati Uniti
sono una nazione
e che le leggi di una nazione
devono essere uguali per tutti
capite oggi è facile
mi sembra vedere come il discorso di Cullen
nella sua lucidità
andasse contro lo spirito del tempo
perché nell'ottocento
e noi italiani ne sappiamo qualcosa
lo spirito del tempo era la nazione
l'unione della nazione
gli interessi sacri della nazione
dire noi non siamo una nazione
era un discorso straordinariamente inquietante
ma anche perdente alla lunga
e in effetti oggi c'è chi dice
guardate che la guerra civile americana
è il momento in cui si è risolta questa cosa
in cui gli Stati Uniti con la forza
sono stati trasformati in una nazione
ora finché si tratta della polemica
o della guerra politica
sulle tariffe doganali
gli interessi del sud
e quelli dell'ovest
tutto sommato sono ancora gli stessi
contadini gli uni
e contadini gli altri
quello che fa
invece davvero saltare
questa grande alleanza
fra il sud e l'ovest
è proprio la grandiosa espansione
degli Stati Uniti
che ormai appunto negli anni 40 e 50
si mangia questo enorme boccone
dei territori conquistati al Messico
e prosegue
arriva all'oceano pacifico
alla fine degli anni 40
c'è la corsa all'oro in California
per esempio
e comincia l'epopea non più del west
ma del far west
del west più lontano
delle guerre con gli indiani
delle pianure
delle carovane di coloni
che si spingono sempre più a ovest
avete presente tutte queste mitologie americane
va all'ovest ragazzo
perché all'ovest c'è appunto
il futuro di una nuova nazione
ora c'è un problema
gli Stati Uniti
com'è la procedura con cui si allargano verso ovest?
funziona così
l'ovest è il nulla
non appartiene a nessuno
appartiene agli indiani semmai
ma appunto si fa pinta che non ci siano gli indiani
appartiene al Messico
ma i messicani sono brutti e cattivi
noi li abbiamo sconfitti
ci prendiamo quel che vogliamo
quando in un certo territorio
che magari è grande come un paese europeo
c'è qualche migliaio di coloni bianchi
questi possono chiedere di essere riconosciuti
come un territorio degli Stati Uniti
non uno Stato ma un territorio
è una tappa intermedia
quando poi dopo qualche anno
gli abitanti bianchi sono ancora aumentati
si può istituire ufficialmente lo Stato
è con questo meccanismo che gli Stati Uniti
diventano sempre più numerosi
sapete che all'inizio
le stelle sulla bandiera
stelle e strisce
erano tredici
sono tredici le colonie
che si ribellano all'Inghilterra
oggi sono 50 le stelle sulla bandiera
50 Stati
via via se ne creano di nuovi
qual è il problema?
il problema è che gli Stati Uniti
si dividono
fra Stati dove la schiavitù è permessa
e Stati dove la schiavitù è vietata
c'è una linea
la linea Mason-Dixon
che attraversa da ovest a est
il territorio
a nord in genere
gli Stati hanno abolito la schiavitù
a sud invece
ci sono gli Stati schiavisti
dico al nord l'hanno abolita
perché fino alla rivoluzione
la schiavitù esisteva in tutti gli Stati Uniti
anche nel nord
anche nel New England
però nel nord non aveva mai
attecchito veramente
perché in un'economia basata
sul commercio
sulla navigazione
sull'industria
il lavoro degli schiavi
non è in realtà utile
mentre invece è utile
nelle grandi piantagioni del sud
vedremo poi quali erano i motivi veri
per cui il nord aveva generalmente abolito la schiavitù
non è così semplice come noi potremmo pensare
ma per adesso lasciamo stare
per adesso mi basta che vi sia chiaro
che il problema nasce quando
bisogna decidere se un nuovo territorio
e poi un nuovo Stato
avrà gli schiavi
oppure non li avrà
e la classe dirigente suddista
spinge perché i nuovi territori
e i nuovi Stati
ammettano la schiavitù
perché l'idea è anche noi così
potremmo spingerci fin lì
a comprare, allargare
creare nuove piantagioni
portare lì i nostri schiavi
se invece in questi Stati
la schiavitù sarà proibita
e saranno solo i contadini del nord
che potranno andare a vivere
a lavorare lì
per gli Stati del Sud
è vitale
che nei nuovi Stati
venga introdotta la schiavitù
tant'è vero che
come dire
dopo la conquista del Texas
strappato al Messico
che ripeto
almeno la mia generazione
si ricorda il film
Alamo
l'Epopea
ecco
piccolo dettaglio
i messicani avevano vietato la schiavitù
quando gli americani conquistano il Texas
naturalmente
reintroducono la schiavitù
nel Texas
perché
quella guerra
è stata voluta
dalle elite del Sud
che in quel momento
comandano
le elite del Sud
hanno bisogno che i nuovi Stati
siano schiavisti
anche perché
ormai è chiaro a tutti
che ci sono blocchi contrapposti
gli interessi
degli Stati industriali
e commerciali
e gli interessi degli Stati agricoli
con gli schiavi
questi interessi si giocano a Washington
e a Washington
un pezzo cruciale
del meccanismo politico
è il Senato
che come forse
o certamente sapete
il Senato degli Stati Uniti
è un'istituzione meravigliosa
ancora oggi
meravigliosa
perché il Senato degli Stati Uniti
è creato
senza alcun rapporto
con la popolazione
degli Stati
ogni Stato
manda due senatori
a Washington
sia Stati minuscoli
che hanno mezzo milione
di abitanti
sia la California
ognuno di questi Stati
manda a Washington
due senatori
e allora
se c'è il blocco
degli Stati schiavisti
bisogna che gli Stati schiavisti
siano il più numerosi possibile
ogni nuovo Stato
con gli schiavi
sono due senatori
del nostro blocco
ogni nuovo Stato
che vieta la schiavitù
sono due senatori
che voteranno
dall'altra parte
la cosa
produce effetti surreali
vi racconto
quando è la prima volta
che ne hanno discusso
si crea
un nuovo Stato
all'Ovest
il Missouri
lì per la prima volta
c'è lo scontro
vogliamo gli schiavi
no
non li vogliamo
alla fine
vincono i sudisti
e il Missouri
nasce come uno Stato
che avrà gli schiavi
ma per dare un compenso
al Nord
viene creato
un nuovo Stato
del Nord
ritagliando
un pezzettino
del Massachusetts
il Maine
che in passato
era stata una colonia autonoma
poi era diventato
parte del Massachusetts
ma adesso
lo ritagliano
dal Massachusetts
si inventano
un nuovo Stato
al Nord
che ovviamente
vieta la schiavitù
e così
avranno anche loro
due senatori
in più
a Washington
a rappresentare
gli interessi
degli Stati
del Nord
con la guerra
al Messico
il problema
si era ripresentato
è fantastico
vedere come
già anni prima
che scoppi la guerra
a Washington
sanno benissimo
che quella guerra
la faranno
che la vinceranno
che gli Stati Uniti
si mangeranno
immensi territori
nel 1846
due anni prima
della guerra
a Washington
stanno già discutendo
ci metteremo
gli schiavi
o non ce li metteremo
in questi nuovi territori
e nel 1846
il senatore
Toombs
della Georgia
Stato del Sud
il senatore Toombs
della Georgia
dichiara in Senato
davanti al Dio vivente
se con le vostre leggi
cercherete di cacciarci
dal Texas
e dal New Mexico
cercherete di cacciarci
vuol dire
vieterete la schiavitù
e quindi noi
piantatori del Sud
non potremo espandere
le nostre aziende
in quelle zone
se cercherete
di cacciarci
dal Texas
e dal New Mexico
io sono
per la secessione
mancano 15 anni
alla vera secessione
il senatore Toombs
della Georgia
sarà poi giustamente
generale
nell'esercito sudista
e fuggirà in Europa
dopo la sconfitta
vabbè poi nel dopoguerra
tornerà
e diventerà rapidamente
di nuovo
il politico più influente
della Georgia
ma questa è un'altra storia
dunque
la conquista del Messico
pone questo problema
sul tavolo
e alla fine
si arriva a un compromesso
al Texas
gli schiavi
il New Mexico
invece gli schiavi
non ci sono
la California
bisognerà vedere
per adesso
sospendiamo
solo che
nel corso
di questo dibattito
viene fuori
la grande novità
politica
che mentre
finora
i piantatori del Sud
e i coloni
dell'Ovest
politicamente
erano alleati
vabbè
su questo fatto
di avere gli schiavi
nei nuovi territori
dell'Ovest
i coloni
non sono mica
tanto d'accordo
perché in realtà
appunto
c'è fame
di terra
tutti vogliono
questi nuovi territori
e i coloni
dell'Ovest
sono piccoli
contadini
non hanno schiavi
non ne hanno bisogno
cominciano a pensare
che perché
dobbiamo dar retta
ai piantatori del Sud
e ammettere
la schiavitù
in questi nuovi territori
e poi
e poi c'è il fatto
che l'Ovest
nel tumultuoso
sviluppo
dell'economia americana
l'Ovest
in quegli anni
40-50
dell'Ottocento
è sempre più legato
economicamente
al nord
pensate alle ferrovie
le ferrovie
negli Stati Uniti
vanno tutte
da est
a ovest
sono come
delle cuciture
che collegano
l'est
con l'ovest
e quindi
il nord
delle industrie
e dei porti
col middle west
agricolo
ormai
grazie alle ferrovie
il grano
la carne
del west
non vanno più
a New Orleans
l'unico porto
del sud
dove si arrivava
scendendo il Mississippi
sui barconi
adesso i prodotti
dell'ovest
vanno a est
vanno a Boston
a New York
in ferrovia
poi c'è
come dire
c'è il fatto
che il nord
industriale
ormai produce
macchine
produce macchine
agricole
e le macchine
al sud
non servono
perché il lavoro
delle piantagioni
di cotone
lo fanno a mano
gli schiavi
e nessuno ha voglia
di investire
nella meccanizzazione
e invece
i piccoli contadini
indipendenti
dell'ovest
le nuove
trebbiatrici
automatiche
le comprano
e come
e nel middle west
nascono nuove città
che dal nulla
diventano metropoli
Chicago
pensate a Chicago
che in pochi decenni
diventa una metropoli
con i suoi macelli
con le sue fabbriche
di carne in scatola
il regno di Al Capone
60 anni dopo
si baserà ancora
su quello
il controllo
dei macelli
dell'industria
della trasformazione
e tutto questo
fa da volano
appunto
fra l'ovest
agricolo
e l'industria
e i porti
del nord
e il sud
del cotone
e degli schiavi
economicamente
si sente sempre
di più
una zona
isolata
dal resto
del paese
e quindi
e quindi capite
se uno dice
come oggi
sempre più
si sente discutere
si sente dire
ma è veramente
sì è la schiavitù
la guerra civile americana
il problema
è stata la schiavitù
sì è vero
certo che sì
però bisogna
capirsi
la schiavitù
è stato il motivo
per cui
gli Stati Uniti
si sono
spaccati
e le teste
più lucide
lo avevano previsto
da molto tempo
già nel 1832
Tocqueville
avete presente
grande viaggiatore
francese
che scrive
libri lucidissimi
sugli Stati Uniti
che ha attraversato
da un lato
all'altro
Tocqueville
già 30 anni
prima
della guerra civile
scriveva
il più temibile
di tutti i mali
che minacciano
l'avvenire
degli Stati Uniti
nasce
dalla presenza
dei neri
nella loro terra
e dunque
la schiavitù
è il motivo
però attenzione
perché non dobbiamo
tradurre questa cosa
in un discorso
come dire
moralistico
o umanitario
con i buoni
da una parte
che vogliono abolire
la schiavitù
e i cattivi
dall'altra
che invece
la vogliono tenere
la questione
è che si tratta
dell'egemonia
di un settore
o dell'altro
perché il nord
aveva abolito
la schiavitù
o intendiamoci
fra le elite
colte del nord
come fra quelle
europee
nel settecento
il discorso
sul fatto
che la schiavitù
è una cosa indegna
e che bisogna abolirla
questi erano discorsi
che si facevano
naturalmente
ma sono discorsi
ripeto
elitari
che non hanno
quasi nessuna presa
nell'opinione pubblica
popolare
del nord
e dell'ovest
il nord
ha abolito
la schiavitù
perché
il suo sistema
economico
si basava
sul lavoro
di operai
di marinai
i quali
non volevano
la concorrenza
degli schiavi
non volevano
che i padroni
potessero utilizzare
schiavi
e quindi
ovviamente
schiacciare
la capacità
contrattuale
degli operai
bianchi
questa cosa
non la dico io
l'ha detta per esempio
il secondo presidente
degli stati uniti
john adams
nordista
john adams dice
siamo all'inizio
dell'ottocento
il massachusetts
ha abolito
la schiavitù
la vera
causa
fu il
moltiplicarsi
dei lavoratori
bianchi
che non
intendevano
permettere
oltre
ai ricchi
di rivolgersi
a questi concorrenti
dalla pelle
scura
se i proprietari
avessero ottenuto
per legge
il permesso
di tenere
schiavi
la gente
del popolo
avrebbe
ammazzato
i neri
e forse
anche i loro
padroni
questo è il modo
in cui il secondo
presidente degli
stati uniti
valutava
le motivazioni
che avevano portato
gli stati del nord
a abolire
la schiavitù
e del resto
che le motivazioni
non fossero
umanitarie
lo dimostra
il fatto
che molti
stati del nord
come New York
e anche
quasi tutti
i nuovi stati
dell'ovest
avevano leggi
che negavano
il voto
ai neri
liberi
gli vietavano
di andare a scuola
vietavano
ai neri
di far parte
delle giurie
proibivano
i matrimoni
misti
in qualche caso
vietavano addirittura
la residenza
ai neri
l'Illinois
lo stato
di Lincoln
aveva una legge
che proibiva
l'ingresso
nello stato
a qualunque
nero
libero
che non fosse
già residente
in altre parole
quelli che ci sono
non li possiamo
buttare fuori
ma non ne vogliamo
altri
e d'altra parte
al sud
all'inizio
dell'ottocento
si discuteva
seriamente
di abolire
la schiavitù
perché lì
fra le elite
colte
effettivamente
l'impatto
morale
di questa cosa
e anche
la sensazione
che fosse
da un punto di vista
economico
un sistema
arcaico
non veramente
redditizio
ecco
questo fa sì
che al sud
all'inizio
dell'ottocento
il dibattito
sul fatto
che forse
era meglio
abolirla
la schiavitù
c'era
e in particolare
alla fine
nei primi anni
dell'ottocento
si decide
di abolire
non la schiavitù
perché sarebbe
un passo enorme
però di abolire
la tratta
degli schiavi
in altre parole
gli schiavi
che ci sono
ce li teniamo
ma è inumano
andare ancora
a prenderne altri
l'abolizione
della tratta
viene decisa
a Washington
sotto la presidenza
di Jefferson
sudista
proprietario
di schiavi
il quale però
è assolutamente
convinto
che la schiavitù
prima o poi
andrà superata
e che quindi
intanto è meglio
evitare che si
espanda troppo
capito?
al sud c'è anche
chi fa due conti
e comincia ad avere
paura
quanti sono
questi neri
nel 1860
i neri
negli Stati Uniti
sono 4 milioni
e mezzo
di cui 4 milioni
di schiavi
sono il 14%
della popolazione
degli Stati Uniti
la stessa percentuale
di adesso
identica
ma nel sud
sono il 40%
stanno tutti lì
praticamente
e allora
al tempo
della rivoluzione
della guerra
di indipendenza
americana
al sud
era normale
sentir dire
che la schiavitù
era una cosa
arcaica
immorale
da superare
il primo presidente
George Washington
grande piantatore
della Virginia
e padrone
di 200 schiavi
che peraltro
libererà
per testamento
George Washington
non si faceva scrupolo
di dire
la schiavitù
a me
ripugna
politici
meridionali
popolarissimi
in quegli anni
non avevano
nessun problema
al sud
in quegli anni
e badate
fine 700
inizio 800
poi la musica
cambierà
e lo vedremo
ma in quegli anni
anche i politici
più popolari
del sud
non avevano
nessun problema
a dire in pubblico
che la schiavitù
era una pratica
abominevole
un cancro
sul nostro volto
e ancora
nel 1832
anno fatale
che mi accorgo
di aver già citato
parecchie volte
l'assemblea
della Virginia
il Parlamento
il più importante
stato del sud
discute una mozione
per l'abolizione
della schiavitù
non passa
ma per pochi voti
soprattutto perché
mentre all'inizio
tutti quanti
possono anche essere
d'accordo
che prima o poi
la schiavitù
bisognerà superarla
però nel concreto
nel concreto
cosa facciamo
poi
gli schiavi
l'abbiamo detto
sono un capitale
gigantesco
non è che li puoi
come dire
la proprietà privata
è sacra ragazzi
siamo in America
e non è che tu puoi
togliere alla gente
una gigantesca
proprietà privata
senza risarcire
i proprietari
e con quali soldi
e poi soprattutto
una volta
che hai liberato
i neri
cosa gli dici
di fare
il dibattito
si arena lì
perché in realtà
nessuno si immagina
che i neri
possano continuare
a vivere
da liberi cittadini
negli Stati Uniti
insieme ai bianchi
bisogna mandarli
da qualche parte
nei primi decenni
dell'ottocento
quando si discute
sull'abolizione
della schiavitù
al sud
nascono anche
le società
per rimandare
in Africa
i neri liberi
la soluzione è quella
società umanitarie
che raccolgono
capitali
e lo fanno
creano una colonia
in Africa
comprando
un vasto territorio
lo chiamano
Liberia
e cominciano
a finanziare
il trasferimento
in Africa
di schiavi liberati
tutto questo avviene
sotto la presidenza
di Monroe
che è uno dei presidenti
sudisti
e padroni di schiavi
che incoraggia
fortemente
questo progetto
per rimandare
in Africa
i neri
tanto che la capitale
della Liberia
che dopo qualche anno
diventa uno stato
indipendente
si chiamerà
e si chiama tuttora
come sapete
Monrovia
in onore
del presidente
Monroe
proprietario
di schiavi
e fautore
del rimandare
in Africa
gli schiavi
man mano
che riusciamo
a liberarli
in qualche decennio
rimandano
in Liberia
qualcosa come
15.000
neri
liberati
i quali
peraltro
in Liberia
creano
piantagioni
e riducono
in schiavitù
gli indigeni
ma questo
è un altro discorso
il modello
di società
che hanno in testa
è quello
ora
ora il punto è
che queste cose
che vi sto dicendo
valgono per il sud
dei primi anni
dell'ottocento
ma al tempo
dell'elezione
di Abraham Lincoln
non è più vero
nel 1860
nessun politico
del sud
oserebbe più dire
la schiavitù
va abolita
è immorale
o così via
perché
perché è cambiato
il clima
una causa
è economica
e
devo dire
che ci mostra
la potenza
dell'economia
cioè
la potenza
con cui
i fattori economici
riescono a plasmare
la mentalità collettiva
l'opinione pubblica
perché il fatto
che all'inizio
dell'ottocento
l'economia del sud
non era così ricca
sia appunto
la canna da zucchero
il tabacco
il cotone
ma i profitti
erano modesti
e molti
potevano dire
non è un sistema
economico
che abbia un futuro
invece la rivoluzione
industriale
ha cambiato tutto
con la rivoluzione
industriale
ve l'ho detto prima
ma adesso
acquista un altro
significato
capite la cosa
con la rivoluzione
industriale
la produzione di cotone
per mezzo di schiavi
si rivela
un modo
per fare
un sacco
di soldi
e allora
sono sempre meno
quelli che dicono
no la schiavitù
è un sistema
arcaico
da superare
no no
le cifre
sono cifre
la schiavitù
produce
enormi profitti
il risultato
fra l'altro
è che il valore
il prezzo
degli schiavi
sale
vertiginosamente
oltretutto
hanno vietato
la tratta
anche se di nascosto
continua lo stesso
navi
del nord
di boston
di new york
continuano
a fare la spola
e a scaricare
clandestinamente
schiavi
importati
dall'africa
però
ufficialmente
è abolita
e quindi
il prezzo
degli schiavi
sale
allo scopio
della guerra civile
uno schiavo
vale tranquillamente
mille dollari
in un'epoca
in cui un bracciante
prende
otto dollari
al mese
risultato
il sistema
della schiavitù
ce l'avamo sbagliati
non era mica
così arcaico
così superato
proprio per niente
è un sistema
che garantisce
giganteschi profitti
e poi c'è un'altra
c'è un'altra ragione
per cui al sud
il discorso
aboliamo la schiavitù
cessa di risuonare
ed è ideologica
invece stavolta
e anche qui si vede
quanto è importante
l'ideologia
come è capace
di accecare
quando si prende
troppo sul serio
e quando crea
spaccature
tra due fronti
contrapposti
perché l'altra
grande novità
dopo il 1820-30
è la nascita
dell'abolizionismo
la nascita
cioè di un movimento
religioso
puritano
che prende piede
al nord
e che critica
la schiavitù
da un punto di vista
morale
e che con crescente
energia
reclama
l'abolizione
della schiavitù
subito
senza tante
discussioni
senza risarcire
nessuno
perché la schiavitù
è vergognosa
e quelli che hanno
gli schiavi
hanno fatto il patto
col diavolo
e bruceranno
all'inferno
e non meritano
nessun rispetto
e in un paese
cristiano
la schiavitù
deve essere
abolita
il movimento
abolizionista
è un grande
movimento di opinione
che si diffonde
nel nord
che non penetra
mai granché
fra le masse
ma che a livello
di elite colte
invece
a partire
dagli anni
30-40
dell'ottocento
guadagna
grande spazio
risultato
al sud
si spaventano
sempre di più
sentendo i toni
dell'abolizionismo
al sud
si irrigidiscono
per un politico
del sud
continuare a dire
come prima era normale
sì in fondo
la schiavitù
prima o poi
bisognerà superarla
diventa impossibile
non ti rieleggono
semplicemente
uno dei politici
che nel 1832
aveva votato
in Virginia
per abolire
la schiavitù
diventa poi
governatore
della Virginia
e però
di abolire
la schiavitù
non ne parla più
e quando un amico
del nord
gli chiede
come mai
risponde
io non ho
cambiato idea
ma i vostri
abolizionisti
ne hanno fatto
un argomento
vietato
tra di noi
parlare contro
la schiavitù
è la morte politica
nel sud
ripeto
non ti vota più nessuno
e dunque
capite cosa sta succedendo
sta succedendo
che gli stati del sud
si sentono ormai
un settore del paese
isolato
che ha interessi
contrapposti
al resto del paese
e che i propri interessi
li identifica
con la schiavitù
la schiavitù
bisogna difenderla
a tutti i costi
altrimenti
il nostro sistema
finirà in minoranza
e noi siamo spacciati
e quindi
gli intellettuali
del sud
smettono
di parlare male
della schiavitù
e cominciano
a difenderla
il dibattito
sulla schiavitù
negli anni 30
assume questa connotazione
nuova
cominciano a comparire
politici
ideologi
pensatori
teologi
predicatori
protestanti
del sud
sono in prima linea
schiavitù
è una roba sacrosanta
c'è nella Bibbia
cominciano a comparire
teorici
che difendono
la schiavitù
con argomenti
affascinanti
esempio
ma credete
che gli operai
del nord
stiano meglio
ma al nord
gli operai
sono sfruttati
in modo ignobile
vergognoso
si spaccano
la schiena
per quattro soldi
noi i nostri schiavi
li trattiamo
bene
e sono felici
citazione
da uno dei discorsi
di quell'epoca
i nostri schiavi
sono felici
soddisfatti
paghi
e del tutto
incapaci
vista la loro
inferiorità intellettuale
di crearci il minimo problema
sono una razza inferiore
volevate rimandarli in Africa
al paganesimo
alla superstizione
teniamoceli qua
godono di tutti i benefici
della civiltà
e della religione cristiana
ovviamente
devono essere schiavi
ma pensate che potrebbero
governarsi da soli
ma non fatemi ridere
tutti sono d'accordo
negli Stati Uniti
ben inteso
che esistono le razze
e che le razze
si dividono
fra razze superiori
e razze inferiori
razze più evolute
razze più arretrate
razze che forse
un giorno
arriveranno al nostro livello
ma per adesso
non ci sono ancora arrivate
i discorsi
che si sentono fare
al sud
sono questi
volete liberarli
e poi
vedrete
l'anarchia
cominceranno
a far di tutto
a rubare
ad ammazzare
bisognerà sterminarli
volete questo
sono così felici
da schiavi
il bello
è che questi discorsi
fanno molta presa
al sud
anche fra quella maggioranza
della popolazione bianca
che gli schiavi
non li ha
perché
a possedere
schiavi
è una grossa
minoranza
dei bianchi
del sud
ma la maggioranza
non ha schiavi
e però
però i sostenitori
del sistema
in realtà
riescono a presentarla
in modo tale
che anche chi
non è personalmente
interessato
perché non possiede
schiavi
però sente
che la schiavitù
è un vantaggio
per lui
c'è chi spiega
molto seriamente
e tra l'altro
notate lo sforzo
intellettuale
che viene dispiegato
in questa causa
per difendere
la schiavitù
dice in ogni società
ci deve essere gente
che fa i lavori più duri
più pesanti
e in tutte le società
è gente pagata male
che vive peggio
degli altri
e da noi
nessun bianco
fa dei lavori duri
e pesanti
e vive male
da noi i bianchi
sono tutti liberi
e tutti uguali
questa è la democrazia
noi abbiamo
la democrazia
dove i bianchi
sono tutti uguali
e questo
perché
appunto
abbiamo un'altra razza
che fa
i lavori sporchi
e così si riesce
nel capolavoro
di convincere
i bianchi poveri
che la schiavitù
è la garanzia
del sogno americano
della libertà
dell'uguaglianza
e per i padroni
questo vuol dire
che il sud
è al sicuro
da quell'altro
incubo
che si sta diffondendo
nel mondo
alla metà
dell'ottocento
e cioè
la lotta
di classe
in Europa
sono anni ormai
che si parla
di operai
sfruttati
insoddisfatti
scioperi
minacce di rivoluzione
lo spettro
del comunismo
che nel 1848
Marx e Engels
diranno appunto
a legge
in Europa
al sud
il problema
ma non esiste
i bianchi
sono tutti contenti
e soddisfatti
e a favore
del sistema
il senatore
Tums
che ho già citato
prima
descriverà così
quattro anni prima
dello scoppio
della guerra civile
la situazione
al sud
stabilità
progresso
ordine
pace
soddisfazione
e prosperità
regnano
all'interno
delle nostre
frontiere
nel nostro
territorio
sconfinato
non abbiamo
bisogno
neanche
di un solo
soldato
per difendere
la società
il desiderio
di un cambiamento
radicale
non si manifesta
da nessuna
parte
il sud
si sente
forte
e l'ottimismo
fa nascere
una minoranza
estremista
che vuole
sempre di più
abbiamo sconfitto
il Messico
adesso è ora
di conquistare Cuba
di allargarci
in Sud America
nuovi territori
da aprire
alle piantagioni
e alla schiavitù
nasce addirittura
un movimento
per riaprire
la tratta
degli schiavi
con l'Africa
che Jefferson
aveva abolito
50 anni prima
alla fine degli anni 50
al Parlamento
del South Carolina
un deputato
presenta una mozione
per la riapertura
della tratta
la mozione
peraltro
era spinta
quel deputato
si chiamava
Maxi Gregg
e sarà poi
anche lui
un generale
sudista
ucciso
alla battaglia
di Fredericksburg
dunque
il Sud
si sente forte
ed è disposto
ad andare
allo scontro
per difendere
i suoi interessi
si sente forte
soprattutto
perché il cotone
sembra
una garanzia
assoluta
l'industria europea
ha bisogno
del cotone
del Sud
come disse
il governatore
del South Carolina
al senato
degli Stati Uniti
voi non oserete
far guerra
al cotone
nessuna potenza
sulla terra
osa farlo
il cotone
è re
cotton is king
questo è lo slogan
che i giornali
e i politici
suddisti
ribattono
a sua volta
l'opinione pubblica
del nord
comincia a spaventarsi
ma cosa vogliono
questi schiavisti
cos'è questa storia
ma vogliono davvero
comandare loro
in tutti gli Stati Uniti
vogliono venire
a comandare
anche a casa nostra
per caso
questi padroni
di schiavi
si diffonde
nell'opinione pubblica
del nord
la preoccupazione
della cospirazione
degli schiavisti
del potere schiavista
slave power
lo sappiamo tutti
con che forza
i giornali
impongono
nel discorso pubblico
certe etichette
che poi tutti ripetiamo
senza più pensarci
il sovranismo
il populismo
ecco lo slave power
una volta che l'hai creato
esiste
la gente al nord
comincia a avere paura
i piantatori del nord
del sud
i piantatori del sud
sono
un arrogante
gruppo di potere
che complotta
per dominare
gli Stati Uniti
e tutto questo
appunto
plasma l'opinione pubblica
e abitua
nordisti
e sudisti
a considerarsi
due nazioni
diverse
per i sudisti
il nord
vuol dire
disordine
immigrazione straniera
città fumose
miseria operaia
puritanesimo
ipocrita
dominio brutto
del denaro
per i nordisti
il sud
è
arretratezza
pigrizia
immoralità
una palla al piede
per il progresso
degli Stati Uniti
perfino le chiese
protestanti
si spaccano
le chiese
i battisti
i metodisti
che sono i più forti
nell'opinione pubblica
di massa
beh
ci sono i battisti
del nord
e i battisti
del sud
quelli del nord
che reclamano
l'abolizione
della schiavitù
basandosi
sulla Bibbia
e quelli del sud
che dichiarano
che la schiavitù
è perfettamente giusta
basandosi
sulla Bibbia
e al sud
man mano
che si rendono
conto
che ormai
il conflitto
di interessi
non può più
essere ricucito
cominciano a pensare
al piano B
e cioè
se questi qua
diventano troppo
influenti a Washington
e noi ci troviamo
in minoranza
ce ne andiamo
facciamo la secessione
tornano attuali
quei discorsi
che John Callum
faceva anni prima
e cioè
noi non siamo
una nazione
siamo una libera
unione di stati
questo tema
dei diritti
degli stati
capite politicamente
è cruciale
al sud
il discorso è
il South Carolina
o la Virginia
sono stati sovrani
che hanno accettato
di entrare
in questa unione
e se ne possono andare
quando vogliono
nel 1850
si sta appunto
discutendo
del nuovo
stato di California
e
se ammettere o no
la schiavitù
in California
per la prima volta
mancano dieci anni
all'elezione di Lincoln
per la prima volta
nel 1850
si riunisce
una convention
una convenzione
di delegati
di tutti gli stati
del sud
per discutere
se la politica
di Washington
non va nella direzione
che vogliamo noi
cosa possiamo fare
e lì per la prima volta
si sente dire
da parecchi
appunto
ce ne andiamo
poi in realtà
capite
tra il momento
in cui cominci a dirlo
e il momento
in cui ci pensi
sul serio
ce ne corre
al senato
si discute
e si cerca
un compromesso
il vecchio
John Callum
che è ancora vivo
ma morirà
fra pochissimo
fa una proposta
molto innovativa
dice
i nostri interessi
non saranno mai conciliabili
facciamo così
facciamo due federazioni
una del sud
e una del nord
collegate
e amiche
fra loro
il senato
si spaventa
anche questo
è troppo
si cerca
un compromesso
al ribasso
il compromesso
è questo
in California
non ci sarà
la schiavitù
il sud
deve inghiottire
questo boccone
ma in cambio
ottiene una cosa
che sembra fondamentale
le autorità federali
si impegnano
a dare la caccia
agli schiavi
fuggitivi
che scappano
dal sud
e arrivano
al nord
è un fenomeno
diffuso
ma non di massa
però è un problema
che esiste
e finora
lo schiavo
che riusciva
ad arrivare
in uno stato
libero
spariva
adesso
il governo
federale
si impegna
a dargli
la caccia
la polizia
federale
negli stati
del nord
caccerà
e arresterà
gli schiavi
fuggitivi
questa cosa
nell'opinione pubblica
del nord
fa un pessimo
effetto
vedere
a casa
propria
che gli schiavisti
riescono a mobilitare
la polizia federale
per dar la caccia
ai loro schiavi
ecco ma allora c'è davvero
lo slave power
ma allora davvero
questi vogliono venire
a comandare a casa nostra
il movimento
abolizionista
si diffonde
c'è sempre più gente
che riflette
sull'immoralità
della schiavitù
e che decide
di impegnarsi
sul serio
per aiutare
gli schiavi
che scappano
nascono le organizzazioni
clandestine
che li aiutano
la ferrovia
sotterranea
si chiama
e nel 1851
esce un libro
che diventa
subito famoso
che si intitola
la capanna
dello zio Tom
ovvero
la vita
fra gli umili
che rappresenta
appunto
in modo molto
oleografico
e dicono gli specialisti
abbastanza
immaginario
però appunto
la vita
degli schiavi
nelle piantagioni
del sud
diventa rapidamente
un bestseller
al nord
e dunque
anche se
l'opinione pubblica
del nord
continua a non avere
particolare simpatia
per i neri
e in generale
nessuno vuole i neri
come i vicini di casa
però
però anche al nord
comincia a diffondersi
appunto
l'idea
che forse la schiavitù
è davvero
una cosa sbagliata
e questi del sud
sono davvero
degli immorali
se vogliono
continuare
a tenersi
gli schiavi
e a metà
del decennio
scoppia
una nuova tragedia
la tragedia
del Kansas
il Kansas
è un nuovo
territorio
dell'ovest
è a nord
della linea
Mason-Dixon
che separa
il nord
dal sud
e quindi
al nord
danno per scontato
che nel Kansas
la schiavitù
non ci sarà
il governo
condizionato
dai politici
suddisti
invece
decide
che
se ci sarà
o no
la schiavitù
nel Kansas
lo decideranno
gli abitanti
risultato
sia dal nord
sia dal sud
cominciano a incitare
la gente
a emigrare
nel Kansas
per riuscire
ad avere
la maggioranza
arrivano i coloni
dal sud
per sostenere
la schiavitù
arrivano quelli
dal nord
per sostenere
l'abolizione
siamo nel west
girano tutti
con la pistola
cominciano
le violenze
il 21 maggio
una banda
di meridionali
attacca
una cittadina
abitata
da nordisti
Lawrence
la saccheggia
distrugge
la tipografia
dei giornali
locali
che erano
appunto
abolizionisti
quattro giorni
dopo
il 25 maggio
i nordisti
rispondono
con quello
che è passato
alla storia
come il massacro
di Potawatomi
una banda
di abolizionisti
si presenta
di notte
appunto
in questa zona
del fiume
Potawatomi
a casa
di un colono
del sud
prelevano
il padre
e due figli
li portano
nel bosco
li ammazzano
a colpi
di spada
poi vanno
a casa
di un secondo
colono
lo portano fuori
lo ammazzano
a coltellate
poi vanno
alla capanna
di un terzo
colono
ci trovano
il padrone
e tre ospiti
li interrogano
per sapere
chi sono
poi ne prelevano
uno
lo portano
nel bosco
e lo ammazzano
il capo
della banda
spiace dirlo
è un personaggio
che abbiamo tutti
sentito nominare
si chiama
John Brown
è il celeberrimo
leader
abolizionista
protagonista
di una canzone
che ai miei tempi
conoscevamo tutti
già da bambini
e gli altri
della banda
sono i suoi figli
i suoi amici
John Brown
il capitano
come si fa chiamare
uno che viene dal nord
ed è un abolizionista
religioso
convintissimo
convinto
che la schiavitù
è il male assoluto
e che va distrutta
e che gli schiavisti
vanno annientati
e ha fatto giurare
ai suoi figli
di lottare
fino alla morte
per abolire
la schiavitù
ed è convinto
di poter far insorgere
gli schiavi
adesso sta operando
nel Kansas
tra poco
lo ritroveremo
da un'altra parte
saremo ormai
veramente
alla fine
della nostra
carrellata
un caso
come quello
del Kansas
ovviamente
scatena
l'opinione pubblica
da una parte
e dall'altra
come potete bene
immaginare
ognuno
vede soltanto
le violenze
degli altri
e di conseguenza
in tutto il paese
si parla
del Kansas
si insanguinato
bleeding
Kansas
però per quelli
del nord
vuol dire
che gli schiavisti
ammazzano
e per quelli
del sud
vuol dire
che i maledetti
abolizionisti
ammazzano i nostri
e nel 1857
come vedete
ci avviciniamo
scoppia
un caso
giudiziario
il caso
Dred Scott
è un vecchio
schiavo nero
che è stato
per molto tempo
schiavo di un ufficiale
di un medico militare
e al seguito
del suo padrone
ha soggiornato
a lungo
in vari stati
del paese
dell'unione
fra cui stati
dove la schiavitù
è vietata
dopo la morte
del padrone
Dred Scott
fa causa
alla vedova
sua padrona
sostenendo
che lui
deve essere
considerato libero
perché può dimostrare
che per parecchi anni
ha abitato
in stati
dove la schiavitù
è vietata
il caso
Dred Scott
questo ovviamente
è una patata bollente
gigantesca
nessuno
per cui viene rimbalzato
da un tribunale
all'altro
finché non arriva
alla Corte Suprema
degli Stati Uniti
come sapete
la Corte Suprema
ancora oggi
è un organo giudiziario
di immenso prestigio
e di enorme peso politico
la Corte Suprema
analizza
il caso
Dred Scott
e poi
decide
a maggioranza
una sentenza
esplosiva
e cioè
dichiara
primo
che Dred Scott
è uno schiavo
e non essendo
un cittadino
non ha diritto
di rivolgersi
alla giustizia federale
e di fare causa
a nessuno
secondo
e questo è ancora più importante
a noi può sembrare
ma invece è ancora più importante
è vero
che ai vecchi tempi
c'erano degli stati
dove la schiavitù
era stata vietata
per legge del Congresso
ma secondo
la Corte Suprema
pensandoci bene
il Congresso
non ha nessun diritto
di vietare la schiavitù
in uno Stato
ogni Stato
è sovrano
e per quanto riguarda
la schiavitù
può fare
tutto quello
che vuole
quindi se ai vecchi tempi
quando Dred Scott
stava nell'Illinois
nell'Illinois
la schiavitù
era vietata
non per decisione locale
ma per ordine
del Congresso
quell'ordine
era illegale
non aveva
nessun valore
e quindi
Dred Scott
non ha
nessun diritto
a essere considerato
libero
voi capite
cosa vuol dire
questa cosa
vuol dire
stabilire
appunto
definitivamente
che il governo
di Washington
non ha il diritto
di vietare
la schiavitù
solo i singoli
stati
lo possono fare
e anche
questa sentenza
ovviamente
è esplosiva
e suscita
immense discussioni
e poi
nel 1859
si arriva
all'ultimo episodio
lo sto facendo
molto lunga
come vedete
ma
capite anche
che riassumere
una storia
come questa
in un'ora
ma
ci stiamo avviando
come dire
a stringere
grazie
nel 1859
c'è un ultimo episodio
drammatico
e il protagonista
è di nuovo
John Brown
ha lasciato il Kansas
e adesso
intende fare sul serio
scatenare
la rivolta
degli schiavi
nel sud
perciò
raduna
una banda
e progetta
di impadronirsi
di un arsenale
militare
in Virginia
Harper's Ferry
e distribuire
le armi
ai neri
perciò
nell'estate
del 1859
John Brown
prende in affitto
una fattoria
vicino a Harper's Ferry
e poi
un po' per volta
fa venire lì
i suoi uomini
quando si trova
ad avere
una ventina
di uomini armati
il 16 ottobre
si impadronisce
dell'arsenale
che è pressoché
indifeso
e comincia
a mandare messaggeri
in giro
negri liberi
dico negri
perché a forza
di leggere
le fonti
di quell'epoca
diventa quasi
impossibile
non usare
le parole
che usavano loro
anche se noi
ci siamo abituati
come dire
a fare attenzione
alle parole
che usiamo
e questi
neri liberi
fanno il giro
delle piantagioni
cercando di
convincere
gli schiavi
a insorgere
non si muove
nessuno
arriva la milizia
il presidente
Buchanan
manda da Washington
i Marines
al comando
di un colonnello
che diventerà famoso
è il colonnello
Robert Lee
lo stesso
che di lì a poco
diventerà il comandante
dell'esercito sudista
i Marines
hanno un conflitto
a fuoco
la maggior parte
degli uomini
di John Brown
vengono uccisi
John Brown
viene catturato
processato
condannato a morte
viene impiccato
il 2 dicembre
e lascia
lascia poche righe
in cui dichiara
io
John Brown
sono ora
del tutto certo
che i delitti
di questo
colpevole
paese
non saranno
mai espiati
se non
con il sangue
la morte di John Brown
crea un mito
quel mito
che appunto
esiste
esiste tuttora
nel nord
il giorno
dell'impiccheggione
di John Brown
suonano le campane
in suo onore
sparano salve
di cannone
in suo onore
nasce la canzone
e l'anno dopo
ci sono le elezioni
e alle elezioni
si presenta
un nuovo partito
che vuole
sfidare
l'egemonia
del partito
democratico
un nuovo partito
che prende atto
del fatto
che non è più detto
che l'ovest
sia alleato
con il sud
ormai l'ovest
ha troppi interessi
in comune
con il nord
perciò
si può
spezzare
questa alleanza
il nuovo partito
si propone
appunto
di riunire
gli interessi
degli industriali
del nord
e dei coloni
dell'ovest
e di mettere
in minoranza
il sud
schiavista
e il partito
si presenta
come progressista
è egualitario
e prende il nome
di partito
repubblicano
come vedete
è un paradosso
il partito
repubblicano
e il partito
democratico
esistono
ancora oggi
e oggi
hanno grosso modo
posizioni politiche
come dire
capovolte
rispetto a quelle
che avevano
in quel momento
il partito
repubblicano
si presenta
alle elezioni
con ottime
prospettive
perché il sud
e l'ovest
effettivamente
non vanno più
d'accordo
e quindi
il partito
democratico
si spacca
va alle elezioni
con due candidati
contrapposti
in più c'è un indipendente
e quindi
il partito
repubblicano
diciamo
ha tutte le carte
in mano
per essere sicuri
di vincere
devono appunto
convincere
l'ovest
e perciò
scelgono
come candidato
un uomo
dell'ovest
Lincoln
un avvocato
un politico
di lungo corso
che ha fatto
già esperienza
politica
nel suo Illinois
ma anche
a Washington
e che però
pur essendo
un politico
professionista
è uno
a cui si può
cucire addosso
anche l'immagine
dell'uomo
della frontiera
del figlio
di un colono
cresciuto
in una capanna
di tronchi
l'uomo
che vi capisce
e che vi rappresenta
Lincoln
è un candidato
moderato
il programma
repubblicano
per la sua
candidatura
è estremamente
moderato
per quanto riguarda
il problema
della schiavitù
perché il partito
sa benissimo
che l'abolizionismo
estremo
anche se sta
guadagnando
terreno
però non è ancora
un fenomeno
di massa
e che tra le masse
le idee
abolizioniste
non sono ancora
penetrate
tanto per farvi
un esempio
il Kansas
bleeding Kansas
dove si sono
ammazzati
fra quelli
che volevano
la schiavitù
e quelli
che volevano
abolirla
poi vincono
quelli
che non vogliono
la schiavitù
nel Kansas
perciò
il Kansas
sarà uno stato
senza schiavi
e si dà
una costituzione
in cui si proibisce
l'ingresso
nel Kansas
a qualunque nero
compresi
quelli liberi
perché non volere
la schiavitù
vuol dire
in realtà
non vogliamo
la concorrenza
dei neri
e Lincoln
viene scelto
anche perché
si spera
che non faccia
troppa paura
al sud
perché lui
non è mai stato
un abolizionista
è uno che
come dire
è consapevole
che il problema
andrà poi
affrontato
ma non esita
a dichiarare
che non sa
come fare
vi cito
da un discorso
di Lincoln
in Illinois
anche se
avessi
tutti i poteri
esistenti
su questa terra
io non saprei
cosa fare
con la schiavitù
il mio primo impulso
sarebbe di liberare
tutti gli schiavi
e rimandarli
in Africa
però
riflettendoci
un momento
penserei
che è una cosa
che magari
si può fare
in prospettiva
ma non in tempi brevi
e allora
cosa fare
liberarli
e dar loro
l'eguaglianza
sociale
e politica
i miei
sentimenti
personali
non ammettono
questo
e la grande
massa
della popolazione
bianca
non lo vuole
così
il politico
Lincoln
perciò nel suo
programma
Lincoln dichiara
che sulla schiavitù
lui non intende
mettere becco
e che ogni
stato
è sovrano
e può fare
quello che vuole
per quanto
riguarda
la schiavitù
però al tempo
stesso
il programma
repubblicano
chiarisce
che i suddisti
devono smetterla
di parlare
di diritti
degli stati
di secessione
no
il governo
federale
è superiore
ai singoli
stati
nessuno
stato
ha il diritto
di annullare
le leggi
federali
parlare di
secessione
è tradimento
dal punto di vista
economico
il programma
di Lincoln
è quello che
vogliono
gli industriali
del nord
grandi investimenti
ferrovie
verso l'ovest
e così via
risultato
il sud
compatto
non vuole
Lincoln
e i politici
del sud
presentano
ai loro elettori
Lincoln
come il diavolo
l'abolizionista
addirittura
come un seguace
di John Brown
il quale
John Brown
potete immaginare
quanto fosse
popolare
al sud
in quel momento
risultato
Lincoln
a novembre
vince le elezioni
ma le vince
vincendo il nord
e l'ovest
e in nove
stati del sud
come vi dicevo
non prende
neanche
un voto
se vi chiedete
come sia possibile
che uno non
prenda neanche
un voto
tenete conto
che la democrazia
americana
era all'epoca
una cosa
meravigliosa
il voto
era pubblico
e in generale
uno si doveva
scrivere lui
la sua scheda
elettorale
e andare a portarla
nessuna tipografia
al sud
accetta di stampare
schede elettorali
col nome di
Lincoln
e dunque
si può capire
che se uno
avesse proprio
preteso
di votare
Lincoln
gli facevano
probabilmente
la pelle
vicino di casa
e questo
spiega come mai
in Alabama
Lincoln
non prende
neanche
un voto
ma è stato
eletto
sarà lui
il prossimo
presidente
i repubblicani
hanno vinto
novembre
il 20 dicembre
il South Carolina
proclama
l'indipendenza
e prima
dell'insediamento
di Lincoln
a marzo
altri sei
stati del sud
escono
dall'unione
e poi si mettono
tutti insieme
e formano
la confederazione
ormai siamo
alla fine
ma lasciatemi
ancora citarvi
qualche brano
dal discorso
inaugurale
del presidente
Lincoln
4 marzo
io non ho
nessuna intenzione
di interferire
con l'istituzione
della schiavitù
negli stati
in cui esiste
non credo
di avere
il diritto
legale
di farlo
e non ho
nessuna
inclinazione
a farlo
ma una
dissoluzione
dell'unione
federale
che finora
è stata solo
minacciata
adesso
è in corso
io ritengo
che sulla base
della costituzione
l'unione
di questi stati
è eterna
che nessuno
stato
di sua iniziativa
può uscire
legalmente
dall'unione
perciò
considero
che in base
alla costituzione
e alla legge
l'unione
non è stata
spezzata
e per tutto
quello che posso
fare
farò in modo
che le leggi
dell'unione
siano fedelmente
applicate
in tutti
gli stati
l'idea
della secessione
è l'essenza
dell'anarchia
il potere
della maggioranza
tenuto
sotto controllo
da una serie
di controlli
incrociati
costituzionali
è l'unico
vero
sovrano
di un popolo
libero
chiunque
rifiuta
il governo
della maggioranza
deve precipitare
per forza
nell'anarchia
o nel
dispotismo
fisicamente
parlando
è sempre
il discorso
di inaugurazione
di Lincoln
fisicamente
parlando
non possiamo
separarci
allontanare
le nostre sezioni
l'una dall'altra
né costruire
un muro
invalicabile
fra di loro
non erano
ancora i tempi
di Trump
evidentemente
quelli
un marito
e una moglie
possono allontanarsi
andare a vivere
uno da una parte
e uno dall'altra
dopo il divorzio
noi
non possiamo
e Lincoln
in realtà
in tutto il discorso
Lincoln
si sta rivolgendo
esclusivamente
a quelli del sud
si sta rivolgendo
esclusivamente
a quelli del sud
per convincerli
a tornare indietro
nelle vostre mani
miei compatrioti
insoddisfatti
non nelle mie mani
sta la questione
drammatica
della guerra civile
il governo
non vi aggredirà
non può esserci
nessun conflitto
senza che siate
voi gli aggressori
voi non potete
aver giurato
in cielo
di distruggere
il governo
ma io
ho fatto
il più solenne
giuramento
di conservare
proteggere
e difendere
il governo
e poi finisce così
mi dispiace
dover chiudere
non siamo nemici
ma amici
non dobbiamo
essere nemici
come risultato
dell'inaugurazione
di Lincoln
gli stati suddisti
dichiarano
che tutte le proprietà
federali
sul loro territorio
sono confiscate
comprese
le opere militari
le fortificazioni
quasi tutto
viene occupato
senza colpo ferire
ma nella rada
di Charleston
in South Carolina
c'è una guarnigione
ostinata
che non vuole
abbandonare
il forte
che le è stato
consegnato
il Fort Sumter
la guarnigione federale
continua a tenere
il forte
e non lo consegna
il 12 aprile
le autorità
del South Carolina
fanno aprire
il fuoco
contro
Fort Sumter
il giorno dopo
la guarnigione
si arrende
ma intanto
Lincoln
ha già chiesto
pieni poteri
per reclutare
un esercito
e inizialmente
riprendere
Fort Sumter
poi ovviamente
si decide
di arruolare
70.000 uomini
per tre mesi
con l'idea
che magari tre mesi
tutto sommato
potrebbero bastare
per reprimere
la rivolta
e così
comincia davvero
dopo 30 anni
che se ne parlava
la guerra civile americana
quattro anni
e un giorno
dopo la resa
di Fort Sumter
Lincoln
verrà assassinato
a Washington
la guerra civile
era finita
e la schiavitù
abolita
in tutti gli Stati Uniti
senza riparazioni
senza risarcimenti
senza più minimamente
parlare di alternative
se non quella
l'unica che a quel punto
sembrava praticabile
di permettere ai neri
di continuare a vivere lì
con gli stessi diritti
degli altri cittadini
un enorme progresso sociale
raggiunto
senza che nessuno
ci avesse veramente pensato
senza che seriamente
nessuno lo volesse
fino a poco tempo prima
e in mezzo a una popolazione bianca
che non era affatto preparata
a questo risultato
e che in grande maggioranza
non voleva la parità
né al sud
né al nord
e le conseguenze
si sentono ancora oggi
grazie
grazie a tutti
domani sera
prometto che resto
fino alla fine dell'applauso
adesso invece andiamo a Nanna
arrivederci a tutti
grazie a tutti
Grazie.